al grito de fuera de nuestras plazas y
fascismo nunca más decenas de miles de
italianos salieron a marchar contra la
violencia de grupos neofascistas la
jornada concentró a los principales
sindicatos izquierdistas del país y sus
seguidores quienes exigieron la
ilegalización de estos grupos radicales
y los movimientos fascistas que usan la
violencia deben ser disueltos
pedimos actos concretos no solo charlas
de la solidaridad debemos pasar a la
acción concreta
las imágenes vistas el sábado pasado
impactaron a italia centenares de
militantes neofascistas se tomaron las
calles en el contexto de una
manifestación contra el pase verde
sanitario el grupo force a nueva estuvo
detrás de los ataques a sindicatos y
policías que esto a ser la necesidad de
invadir es necesario reafirmar que el
país no está representado por unos pocos
fascistas alborotadores que fallen oros
y fascistas sino por una multitud de
personas que han saldado sus cuentas con
el fascismo y claramente quieren
superarlo en la boludo superaré
netamente estas escenas han hecho que
muchos recuerden el oscuro pasado de
italia este país vio nacer al fascismo
en 1919 y sufrió una dictadura hasta el
final de la segunda guerra mundial algo
que la mayoría de italianos no están
dispuestos a repetirlo